then not even saying that it's a thing
but she just doesn't tell him and she's
still since she has these accolades and
she doesn't mention it to him because
she just doesn't want to or he doesn't
want her to is she considered a high
value
woman or
just because she's with him yeah a high
value a high value man has to agree that
she's high value he has to pick her yeah
yeah yeah
she can't she can't be a high value
woman unless i hide
yes he has to come in
yeah no he has to pick
what do you mean by commit like as in
like he claims you as well
like that's why that's why i gave the uh
example of lebron lebron james and his
wife he claims his wife online i don't
think it has to be marriage per se but
it has to be it has to be exclusive or
no exclusive enough where everybody
needs to know this is my bee
yeah nobody like you i think she has to
have a ring she is she has to have a
room she has to have a ring i think so
yeah so the reason why i think she has
to have a ring is because that is the
ultimate form of in the west i'll say no
not in the
what
i i think she needs to have a ring
because that's the ultimate form of
commitment to the highest level where a
man has chosen you committed all his
assets his being to you and said
you are mine but now but with that being
said devil's advocate is that being said
you can say our cool
um would a guy would a girl still be
high value she gets cheated on
yes yeah because that that's like
nothing
yeah she's going to yeah
if anything that that increases her
value to a high value man if she if
she's letting him exercise his options
like i think
remember we have to think about it
there's not a lot of rich guys out here
you know not actually he isn't you know
that you might think there is no there i
know there actually isn't a lot of rich
that i have had so i've heard the steps
and it doesn't add up yeah so when it's
like when when a girl meets a guy that's
rich
don't decide like
you're probably not going to meet
another guy like that in the next
hundred guys that you see mm-hmm do you
understand i think i keep on thinking
like a guy
yeah so it's like you have to take your
chances when it comes and if a rich guy
looked like he was talking about the
drake video i guarantee obviously that
was a video and it's entertainment but i
guarantee if he wanted to do that
everyone's 100 percent 100
and girls will they'll be perfectly fine
with it if he walked up to those women
like this sign here he's right here sign
here saying okay we're all married
yes american dream
i have like 20 other girls that are
married to i don't care i'm married
would you do it no stop lying
who else are you married to 20 other
girls no because first of all
that's too much estrogen there's too
much female drama in one situation now
now if
if he's like okay i want to marry
all 20 of y'all but y'all have your own
place i would consider it i would
consider it like i have i don't have to
deal with nobody else and you come over
when you want to and you give me my oh
maybe
give me a week
that's how it is in muslim cultures
where they they have to be able to buy
each wife a house
let me know in the chat if i got it they
have to be asked to be equal if you buy
one yeah yeah yeah yeah
if you want one buy one wife a house you
have to buy them so you would actually
would you prefer that or would you
prefer okay
option one guy you like him a lot
like think about most obsessed you've
ever been with a guy in your life
that dude but more okay okay you got to
share him or
least obsessed you've ever been with a
guy in your life but you get to have him
to yourself
which one you pick in
there's more that comes with it no only
we're only talking about the two
feelings
what do they look like
think about you could think about the
least into a guy that you've been think
of who it was
we're going off on my picks nah i'll
pick the one i'm obsessed with
and that's the thing girls would rather
share an alpha than mary a betta
yeah that's true i'll kill
foreign that's what certain guys
like certain guys don't actually
understand because
guys do struggle with getting girls
nowadays and they don't understand that
yo a girl will
just she'll have she'll share a alpha
guy before she even comes to you
and
i think that's that's why red pill is so
important because guys just have to
realize
what kind of predicament that they're in
and i think once you realize the kind of
predicament that you're in and if you
feel like you're in a
you're in a terrible position that's
your that's your kind of like your cue
to stop you know get get up and start
doing things
i think so i was thinking about
what if we were hypothetically going to
have a high value woman
what would i would put on
on that list hypothetically okay which
i'm not even sure they like i would
argue they exist but if i was going to
i would say we have to do a weight
component where they have to be under a
certain weight yeah no okay
okay
i would say facially they have to be
maybe eight or higher under the age of
27.
okay
and the only way they
and they have to be married to a high
value man
because i just would have a hard time
thinking like could a woman be 55 and
high value
but her value goes down the older she
gets so that doesn't really make sense
to me yeah but i think the beauty of um
like being a wife kind of thing yet
especially with us if you've got a
husband
like i think that kind of like
your beauty kind of it doesn't change to
him kind of yeah he might still come out
and be his husband goggles yeah
yeah even though he might still go out
and like have sex with like some young
bird and whatnot and not care about him
but it's like
he'll he'll probably still love you like
and still remember how beautiful you
were when you don't work together and
whatnot so i don't think you know at 65
70. yeah you'll probably look at me like
you're not as hot as she was like when
you was 23 but you know that you're
still my wife kind of thing you know i
still love you you still gave me these
beautiful children and one yeah i know
he could still love her but i just don't
think she would be in the most desired
category by man
and if we were like because when i think
of high value man it has to be the most
desired category of man
so a high value woman has to be the most
desired category of woman so there has
to be like an age and looks component
see i've got a question right okay
once you say like someone's obtained the
highest valuable man at a certain age so
let's say she's 27 or like she's about
to she's finishing her prime she's
found the guy he's 35 whatever they now
grow all together wouldn't she be
classed as high value still because she
would
she
she hit the goal that she needed to hit
and that was the pinnacle of where you
could argue that but i just but not but
not to society just to that person
possibly to him
but i just have a hard time thinking
like a girl that's 65 is going to be a
high value woman you could argue it i'm
not i'm not sold either way you know
what i mean i personally think like as i
said earlier i think like
one of the only options or one of the
only people that i can look at is lebron
james wife like would who would be like
a high value woman what about michelle i
really love savannah you know michelle
obama no she oh no come on you wouldn't
because she's here she's she's leading
him
a high value woman stays out of the
spotlight
[Music]
like you don't hear nothing about her
would you you don't hear nothing and
that's how i would want my wife to be
you don't hear nothing you don't see her
on the net you don't see her with no
girls and no not guilt trip you don't
see none of that she's she's about her
kids and her man that's it would you
consider
kobe's wife to be
to be honest yeah after only only really
and truly i would maybe consider it
because i only really actually started
to get to know what she's about after
kobe passed
like like before then i didn't really
know who she was but this is the thing
of what you're saying about thingies um
lebron james is like that's the same um
situation you didn't know about because
she was low-key did what she had to do
and you for what i'm saying and there
you go lebron not lebron i mean um kobe
once again r.i.p but um kobe they've
been one of the best athletes there
isn't it
so and i think i think that's what
categorized you as a higher value woman
because think because it's never about
money because think about i think it was
uh sarah that said it on a previous
episode like cristiano ronaldo picked up
a girl that was working at gucci in
retail i understand like she was getting
ten pound an hour
yeah and he picked and he picked her up
and now she's the mother of his three
black children so it's like
this is one of the sorry are you done
one of the things as well i think i
don't feel like a lot of females
understand that in terms of what guys
think how value women are like you
really don't have to be
like yeah you got to be doing something
but you really don't have to be so well
accomplished as guys are and so
competitive as guys in order to be
class or think that you are out of a
high value status do you think a high
value woman can be an average looking
girl
yeah yeah
how
yeah because it's all like so you would
say that looks aren't a component
i think i think looks gets you in the
door
and i think and i think a lot of guys
will like will definitely date like and
or definitely take an average goal
seriously
they'll probably still smash
take average girls seriously
what average girls are they dating i
mean not not every having average
looking not average insider to be fair
wait that's what i mean average
like just face i was just gonna say like
you just said looks will get you in the
door if you ain't got looks how are you
getting through the door no you couldn't
know people outside though you could
like no no no you could no no let's
let's let's like you could just know
someone like and you could be friends
and after just call and then we
time goes by if i'm not in the door i
can't get in the room what
no but i'm trying to say is that's like
like you couldn't oh
that's okay yeah so you could know like
um you could they could just start off
being friends like people have gone into
situations where they started being
friends and then high value mentoring
yeah yeah because look
what's it called you could have a circle
not even a circle you could you name one
yeah name kind of name one example yeah
that's probably good all right so now to
be fair
average looking girl this is what i
wanted to say prior an average looking
girl married to a high value man don't
change the subject name one
i'm gonna be so honest yeah lebron
james's wife when they first got
together
that was before that was before he
became a hot yeah he wasn't a high value
yeah like they met in high school but
now he's but now she's a high valued man
because of because he eventually grew up
to that status
now but he didn't pick her
that's when he was a high value man he
didn't pick her so you're saying enough
to jump yeah
but she was probably hotter when she was
younger though yeah she he said she was
the prettiest girl at his high school i
probably when she was younger i'd
probably give her an eight i mean
so that's what that's what i'm saying
obviously maybe now she's not as pretty
as she was when she was younger but like
obviously like as men we know a woman's
mute beauty kind of like goes away we
know that you understand and i don't
think a man even a high value man i know
we're using lebron as an example but
even him i don't think when they get to
60 he's going to leave his wife because
she's not as pretty as she was when she
was 33 to get me like oh 23 or whatever
but maybe you still banged her 23 year
old you never know do you get me you
maybe still would but i don't think he
would leave yeah because she's not
pretty normal what about you what are
you gonna say um no i was just going to
go off what he said about lebron james
uh
there was something that came out the
other day and i don't know if it's true
or not i've always thought like oh look
i've never heard lebron james like cheat
on his wife or anything and the article
popped up
and it was talking about this female who
was like yeah he flew me out
da da da da
yeah da interesting but then he kind of
replied on the internet oh he's saying
that he's all about his wife
obviously he didn't address her
personally or didn't but he was like oh
like kind of like indirectly you can be
all about your wife yeah no one's going
to confuse me lebron james has never
changed of course
i would never ever try to convince you
of that i think he's cheated as well
he's done a good job at that night being
um
that's what i'm saying and that's how
you know that she's kind of like that's
what i would consider her or his wife as
a high value woman because she doesn't
even make no noise about it it's not